this fuel crisis is a consequence of
demand not supply there's plenty of
diesel and petrol it's just not always
in the right place because there aren't
enough drivers to deliver it the problem
is us buying more than the industry was
prepared for now this is what the
national fuel stock usually looks like
it's the average percentage of storage
being used at garages every week since
the start of last year the top line is
diesel the bottom one petrol in the
middle line is the average you can see
it fluctuates it went up storage during
lockdowns when we were at home and then
it went down when restrictions were
eased and we hit the road but the really
interesting thing is the average is
around 40 percent of storage at any time
so those massive tanks under garages are
never full because 40 is more than
enough to manage normal demand in that
sense the national stock is a bit like
your personal stock it's more economical
and efficient to run your car half full
as long as you're confident you can get
more fuel when you need it now this is
what normal sales look like over the
same period the blue line is the average
weekly sales at a sample of the uk's
filling stations the green line the
pre-covered average and again sales fell
sharply during lockdown one but by last
month they were nudging back to 17 000
liters a week that's 92
of pre-lock down levels of course last
week sales went through the roof the
petrol retailers association says as a
consequence while deliveries are now
getting through 37 of its forecourts
that's up to 2 000 sites still have no
fuel the problems began last friday when
hsbc says it processed 50 more payments
at petrol stations than the week before
with the average spend increasing from
20 pounds to 30 pounds and halfords says
it sold 17 times more jerry cans than
normal at the weekend now the national
emergency plan for fuel lists 10 steps
ministers can take in a crisis five to
maintain fuel supply three of which
they've already activated including
drafting in army drivers and five more
to manage supply and demand including
rationing sales and prioritizing access
for key workers the prime minister says
supplies are stabilizing but if any of
these levers are pulled we'll know that
consumers are skeptical when ministers
say we should calm down perhaps after 18
months of immense disruption we're not
ready to take the chance they might be
wrong